nous recherchons une femme nous avons entendu dire qu'elle se
cache dans le
coin, elle s'appelle Madison Ender, tu t'en
vas Victor, qu'est-ce que tu fais ici les
loups tournent en rond Je suis venu ici pour
t'aider il y a une bagarre à venir nous n'avons pas
assez de bagarre  Pouvoirs J'ai des gens à
protéger Je vais t'aider à sauver
Padre Madison ça fait un moment
Troy ils sont morts ils sont son armée
tu es en infériorité numérique tu n'as plus d'armes ça
ne finit pas bien pourquoi fais-tu ça
il a pris  tout de moi je
fais juste la même chose pour toi
cet endroit c'est tout ce qu'il me reste Victor il
te reste encore quelque chose qui vaut la peine de
se battre pour les gens que nous aimons les
gens pour qui nous donnons nos vies pour le
protéger pourrait vous laisser vivre
pour toujours où est ma fille  où est-
elle, je ne suis plus l'homme que j'étais, personne n'a de
laissez-passer gratuit pour
[Musique]
Je veux savoir où est Padre
[Applaudissements]
G, ça ne peut pas finir comme ça, ça ne peut pas finir
comme
ça